dort so bremst ab es bleibt alles so wie
es hier nicht daran halten egal ob du
hier wird und nicht
durch meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einer weiteren
folge der minecraft kräftige gehen
ich habe wieder viele kräfte mail
zugesendet bekommen über die
kommentarfunktion das heißt wenn ihre
kräftige habt dann schreibt sie einfach
unten die kommentare und dann würde ich
auch sagen können wir direkt an mit der
kräftig idee nummer die wurde mir
zugeredet vom klima arzt und zwar
schreibt sie hier eine idee ein stift
mit dem man bilder schilder bearbeiten
kann sorry falls ich mich mal
versprechen oder eine stimme scheiße ist
ich bin immer noch krank das crafting
rezept sieht wie folgt aus und zwar
einfach auf der linken seite liegt auf
der rechten seite links oben ein eisen
und da drunter ein holz und da drunter 1
der reise soll wahrscheinlich so ein
bisschen für diese blei spitze vorne
dran stehen das holz darunter land so
ein bisschen einfach lästig und holt
keine ahnung dass wahrscheinlich einfach
nur holz immer noch ein stück rein legen
würde wäre es eine schaufel aber das ist
dann auf jeden fall diese diese dieser
stift mit dem man bilder bearbeiten kann
ich weiß wir hatten schon mal den
buntstift jeden fall aber den hat mir
damals nur irgendwelche blöcke an zu
malen aber schilder war immer so die
kann man hinsetzt und kann man da nicht
wieder bearbeiten sondern menschen muss
man es kaputtmachen wieder neue
hinschreiben und das ist dann einfach so
eine sache kamen rechtzeitig drauf
machen und dann kann man das schild
quasi wieder damit bearbeiten das heißt
das crafting in die nummer eins und wir
kommen direkt zu kräftigen immer zwei
nummer zwei wurde mir zugesendet von den
ninja lp minecraft & co und zwar hier
ist eine kräftig für ein regal vergleich
holzbalken hs gleich holz stufe und 0
gleich nichts wir sehen jetzt mal das
crafting rezept eingeblendet und zwar
ganz normal oben drein holzbalken runden
3 holzbalken und in der mitte drei
holzstufen dann haben wir so ein regal
er hat jetzt keine genaue weise
vorgestellt wie man das ganze hätte
nutzen können und so weiter und so fort
aber ich denke einfach dass das ganze
wirklich so ein regal darstellen soll
das so einfach wie sonne holz stufe eine
wand machst allerdings kann man dann
auch sachen drauf stellt also irgendwann
kann natürlich auch endlich ganze blöcke
an die wand machen sich zeigt dass wir
hier so an meiner wand so wie man das
machen können natürlich kann man auch
komplette quadratische blöcke an die
wand packen da etwas drauf stand
allerdings ein regal ist dann halt nur
ein halber blog hat quasi unter kamera
sachen drauf stellen ganz simpel
sache ich glaube so was jedoch
hinzugefügt normalerweise kann man ja
derzeit nichts auf halb blöcke darauf
platzieren
damit wäre es dann möglich mit sommer
egal ob man dafür wirklich neues
crafting rezept braucht sei
dahingestellt
ich denke dass sowas auf jeden fall bald
kommen wird und das ist kräftig nummer
zwei nummer drei ist recht unnötig und
zwar wann mit schreibt mir vielleicht
kann man ja einen donut herstellen
zeitgleich zucker und f gleich farbstoff
ihr seht jetzt mal das kräftig steigen
und zwar oben drein zucker und in die
mitte drei farbstoff beziehungsweise
dann runter das heißt man kann auch in
die mitte drei zucker lägen darunter
dann drei farbstoff der farbstoff
bestimmt dann quasi die farbe des
downloads und den geschmack mehr oder
weniger geschmack ist vielleicht ein
bisschen blöd weil man das ehrlich
schmecken kann aber einfach sobald
beispielsweise wenn man rosen roten
farbstoff da rein tun würde
würzen strawberry dort werden wenn man
irgendwie hat blau ist da rein packe
also lapislazuli wird zum blueberry
dollar kann man sich ganz coole sachen
mit überlegen
ich bin hier allgemein eher so ein typ
habe ich euch ja schon oft gesagt dass
so sachen hinzugefügt werden sollten wie
trinken und auch wer essens
möglichkeiten weil es davon bisher recht
wenig gibt als man kann ich natürlich
irgendwelche schnitzel machen und suppen
130 aber so süßkram es gibt es dazu noch
gar nicht in welche die server fertig
kann man sich auf jeden fall was cooles
auch überlegen und freunde bevor sie da
einige sagen auch das sind viel zu viele
sachen leute ist genug kraft um ideen
das heißt irgendwelche dinge die
eventuell einfach sachen wo man nicht
unbedingt sagt die müssen in vanilla
rein sondern sachen wo man denken könnte
wenn die kommen würden hätten sie
bestimmt die kräftige idee des weges
folge kräftige die du nicht links to be
in minecraft survival oder irgendwie so
aber das war auf jeden fall kräftigen in
matrei und wir machen weiter mit
kräftigen ideen nummer hier
ganz zum blöden tinnitus el fakir das
ist kein tinnitus wasser im ohr glaube
ich vom vom duschen noch oder so wie
komisch wieso es ist ich fühle mich wie
soll ich fühle mich echt krank
kevin hd schreibt einen teddybär
vegleich volle und b gleich brauner
farbstoff das rezept sehen jetzt mal
angewendet und zwar einfach überall
wolle und oben in der mitte einen
braunen farbstoff einfach weiter die
braun ist man könnte da habe ich mir
überlegt eventuell auch noch was machen
mit dem spinnen auge und so war die wehr
hat natürlich auch augen und so weiter
und so fort
das mit dem dem was heinrich grad echt
mega auf aber dann dachte ich mir so
einen spinnen auge ist vielleicht ein
bisschen zu ekelhaft für sonn andy behr
also dass auf jeden fall kräftig von
teddy bär und wie vorhin schon gesagt
muss nicht unbedingt in vanilla kommen
aber wer auf jeden fall der idee für
weitere deko sachen da habe ich euch ja
auch schon mal den letzten folgen gesagt
mit den deko sachen ist auch immer so
eine sache da wird immer gesagt da kommt
noch was und möbel und so und es gibt
auch ganz viele mods die möbel
hinzufügen und so weiter und übrigens
abhol möbel in der nächsten folge wird
zum thema möbel teddybär werde anhalt
quasi einfach so ein stofftier was man
sich dann auch ins zimmer stellen könnte
einfach so eine dekorations sache fand
ich ganz interessant wirklich wie ein
zimmer stellen würde werde andere sache
aber das ist auch schon kräftig die
nummer 4 und wie kommen welche
kinogefühl fünf seht ihr nur den command
and conquer sie den kommentar jetzt
eingeblendet und nicht die kraft indem
weil er mir keinen vorschlag für ein
rezept geschickt hat und zwar schreibt
the shaky ein handy ja nichts neues aber
man sollte eine art von jedem also wo
man mit dias oder so bezahlt also wie
ein verbesserter villiger
ich glaube so was habe ich schon mal
vorgestellt und das ist dann quasi ein
computer ist allerdings werden handy
auch ganz interessant er hat mir halt
kennt rafting rezept zugesendet ist ein
bisschen blöd das heißt ich werde jetzt
auch kein crafting rezept gegen wir
ausdenken oder sondern jetzt einfach den
command mal eingeleitet und es ist eine
frage wie was haltet ihr davon wenn so
technik sachen im micro van oder
hinzugefügt werden natürlich gibt es
modifikationen die schon irgendwelche
solche sachen hinzufügen die
beispielsweise irgendwelche mining
turtles oder auch computer wirklich
teilweise oder auch in der apple mord
und iphone motto hat lässt sich alles da
extrem interessante sachen wollt ihr
wirklich was haltet ihr davon wenn etwas
in hannover kommen würde wäre das viel
oder sagte lee das würde ich schon
respektieren weil vor allem tolle sache
wie mit so einer amazone app da drin bzw
villiger dass man überall handeln kann
ich weiß gibt es dich schon zu viel
werde deswegen den mann habe ich jetzt
einfach mal angenommen zur diskussion
dass der raum steht was haltet ihr von
würdet ihr sagen ja in minecraft muss
mehr so technik sachen und so was alles
oder würde eher sagen
minecraft dort zu bleiben die schiffs
bleibt alles so wie vier eltern erfährt
nichts dran halten egal ob du hier bett
und nicht und damit verabschiede ich
mich auch schon hier von euch in dieser
crafting gegen folge sorry dass man da
so ein bisschen zu sitzen ich bin da dam
vorproduzieren einfach dass ich jetzt
vier videos für die tage vor produziert
das übers wochenende und mich dann
einfach mal ausreden kann um genesen
kann und dann sehen wir uns in einem
nächsten video wieder wenn es wieder
heißt kontrakte
ist